ciao ragazzi alle mie spalle
praticamente è buio oggi ho lavorato
montato un pochino di cose quindi posso
mettermi a girare in realtà solamente
adesso questa puntata di il meraviglioso
vlog mas della domenica che sarà secondo
me un mash up con cucina buttata con lui
a differenza che abbiamo deciso di non
preparare nulla non so bene come che
faremo oggi gli ospiti sono oggi
gianmarco e rickler rimbalzare ospiti
[Musica]
beatrice che si sta guardando
gente che mangia ho sempre rimesso
adegui invece forse sono pazzo ma io amo
vedere gente che mangia e di lato
soprattutto in questi video nettuno
anche il conteggio delle calorie a un
piacere unico quello che provo io posso
dire cosa c'è del bello del vedere gente
che mangia uno ti fa venire fame 2 ti dà
soddisfazioni ma non stai mangiando
davvero quindi in realtà ti senti qua
venire fame magiari cioè subiti che
unire le maniche e di natale a miti
sfondi di cibo vendita le sarebbe bello
nutrirsi delle loro emozioni
potete loro feci posso proporre una cosa
il commento tu no noi voglia di una
merenda
io propongo invece una cosa prima
mangiamo e poi decidiamo che cosa
cucinare e mangiare durante e ho avuto
l'idea
la domanda è non ci sarà
ok dolce quindi dolce abbiamo detto bada
il natale è dolce non è salato siamo in
un momento molto molto importante
avevano alimentare qual è stato il
grande cambiamento che ad oggi si può
definire proprio una pietra miliare
della scoperta della cucina mondiale
otto le leggi della cucina ma io dico
effettivamente quartiero marchesi il
nostro marchese un'edizione che ha
completamente stravolto le regie da
cucina
il microbo tutto il costo è andato
l'amico era nella tua cucina
ti ringrazio che è molto veramente di
nutella biscuits se dicendo ma che ha
stravolto ha stravolto completamente la
cucina della biscuit per cucina buttata
nessuno li trovi per la b schizzi da
farci per mercato lo ritrovi ragazze
avuto l'idea non ero a fuoco usate
adesso sono a fuoco ho avuto l'idea
originale l'hai detto tu non si trovano
inseriamo a farvi noi cioè vuoi valide
scatola della no voglio fare la
scarpetta nella media
adesso si va a comprare sia gli
ingredienti per farli che i nutella bis
che vediamo se si trovano domanda chi ci
va un amico vai a prendere l'olio c'è da
fare mi spiace c'è da fare beh davis e
tu che sei nostri appena arrivato da
profumo una cosa democratica
no io dico di no rosati che ci medico di
bordo come anticipato enrico io io ok la
maggioranza facciamo così vado io e tu
lavori l'effetto non ci facciamo
estrazione bar la sorte vado a preparare
tutto quanto chi non barare
no non parlare non vogliono avere come
vuoi fare distrazione ma facciamo quei
biglietti la classica di punirla ragazzi
tranquilli controllo io è che quello
sappiamo tutti come fa a me non piace
questo strano sotterfugio in cucina ve
lo dico spero che non ci siano 4
giammarco controlli e mandiamo che tutto
va bene
potremo così da quanto sei lento a fast
i bigliettini nel secondo
[Musica]
pronto il pari ma onesto non essere tu
sei uno stregone
non lo so poi c'è stata una
manipolatrice gelmo enrico la bella eva
nuovo sono io senso ma c'era e famelico
di virtù guglielmo myterna questa
ricetta certi premio liszt e li trovo
veri prendo quelli della dipartita le
persone che la domenica non hanno avuto
ma fanno in format preferito dal
castello deruta biscuit è più facile che
va bene non scappi dal supermercato non
ha mai ci vado però maledetti di
sterilizzazione altre ma non è stato
sciocco
poi già mi sta squillando jam in bagno
da quassù vacuità mi ami non prendere
pronto poi dimmi croce stanno presente
la lista che ti ho mandato ma se uscito
sei incassi pronto
hai presente la lista della spesa che ti
ho mandato e quindi interni quale cose
sa troppo bene va bene attacca voleva
riva
[Risate]
tornato lavorati precari no non e renda
deliziosa posso aprirla no la farina di
nocciole non c'era dove dovremo
frullarle nel mischiare alla farina
penso sia un processo giusto nostra
iniziativa a v da me lo so chi non c'era
almeno affrontare non va bene
[Musica]
io ho visto che stavi per scaldare stato
parlandole ci sia lui sarebbe morto
senza tentare di vorrei far vedere il
mio dito perfettamente pulito gialle
cade così è stato fino al polso
allora mentre enrico monti parole file
si definisce cmc del videomaker ok
vediamo la tremola di di meno ok
buttiamoci il grembiule però dai blog ma
rimango in cucina buttata metti il
grembiule ormai mettiamo un grembiule
natalizio cioè eccoci funziona io ho il
terrore di prendere fuoco da un momento
all'altro o comunque rimane fulminato da
questa cosa aveva fatto non fatelo a
casa tu sei attaccato proprio fa la
corrente è il blog mas a cucinare
cento grammi di zucchero mi raccomando
ragazzi in pasticceria bisogna essere
assolutamente precisissimi qui saranno
100 ton di 100 100 pochissimo e bucato a
mente vogliamo non vedi precisissimi
cento guarda grado di nuovo ecco hai
ragione al 100
erano mesi qua dentro perché è aperto
già la nutella che all'ultimo
procedimento perché questo qui o quanto
tubero c per farli imola va la vicenda 6
stimolato tu sei un grande fabbrica il
prodotto sono un grande maiale 150 g di
burro freddo di frigo a tocchetti mai il
nostro caro parente preistorico
e di con diretto discendente dei
dinosauri ed è presente quale razza
secondo te sono un brontosauro il bravo
grandi bravo granelli chi è regolare
alzati una punta di vanillina domanda
niente
no non puoi fare questa lamentela
l'hotel ha già mandato in passato in
renault bizkit appena sono usciti però
nutella perché non possiamo essere più
generosi come vorresti 50 kg di nutella
per mille note dal dischetto
mammamia sai quanto di antigeni lisa è
veramente a quel punto ma assai
contrariato felice al dito vader diventa
meno felice almeno avvenne anche la
ferrero rai se ne va bene chiunque sia
disposto a farmi mai ne aggiungiamo un
uomo a guglielmo tu sei un porco
veramente l'ora nocciole in nutella sono
belle
ho perso l'ho persa l'inclusione
maledetto d'accordo per fare la farina
mettiamo 50 grammi di nocciole dentro un
sacchetto a terra nova 14950 cisco la
sevel
[Musica]
schiacciata salviamoci in piedi ma come
il peso umano per ora passata alla
storia di uno chef con cui lavoravo per
cucinano poiché è di un cliente molto
antipatico rientro in cucina e gli disse
sbrigati
fammi un petto di pollo che ho fretta
bello fino per favore mi disse ok appena
uscito il cliente dalla cucina ha preso
il petto di pollo dal frigo loro il
bello fino lo sbatte per terra e lo
comincia a calpestare come tu hai fatto
con ma così a secco certo preso la prima
mangiava da mangiare
sì se n'è andato mai a fermare i fuochi
non puoi sapere che cosa faranno di
illegale di non probabile bisogna
avvicinare la farina con le lame in modo
da essere sicuri che avere una bella
farina e poi per gli aggiungiamo tutti
gli ingredienti è così va bene le cacce
salgo io sta facendo bene se beba si può
veramente giunto a salvarci a questa
roba qui aggiungiamo quello di prima
impressionante lo so c'è con la farina
non è facile invece per me è un gioco da
ragazzi
e ora se non sbaglio abbiamo finito la
rossa dell'impasto che turisti
aspettarmi
e molto sudato stranissima bene alle
nocciole è vero sono le nocciole che
stanno sudando in frigo per 40 minuti e
mai come adesso qualcosa ci digeriremo
lo stomaco lo so sono il grande
benefattore di questo blog ma allora un
bel succhietto lo vuole per caso che ne
fanno tre hanno nemmeno una e mezza
album non ho contato benissimo
si è insomma incisivamente io volevo
assaggia questa è questo succede appare
noi riprese mentre si mangia bene le
parole ma prendi nava perché ma ragazzi
la guarda non ne vada per caratura che
schifo come piace guardare gente che
mangia mentre un angelo ma guarda che se
stamani a questa può essere l'ultima
dieta tu mangi di purezza tami chiave di
questo e si sfonda e pensi di mangiare
quella roba lì che poco alla volta mi
sono visto uno che mangia queste specie
di gambe di granchio quindi calcola che
erano una cosa grossa così con la zampa
alla fine è questa qua aveva una ciotola
di fonduta di formaggio davanti quindi e
poi tipo tipo succhiava tutto quanto
ritirava fuori e mordina solo alla fine
rispettando l'idea del è uscito buono è
durissimo ti vuoi mettere il suo
grembiule devo spendere a questo punto
il biscotto 4 mm nel video dice non mi
interessa se deve andare a occhio nostro
se non è così
ma perché l'ho detto io biscotti se come
verranno un pochino più grandi
biscottoni pizze delle grandi pizze
togliamo due terzi io già anche in
questo caso non è buono processo che
cosa fare pregare arma segreta st
cambiasso brusco a pagarne cerchi
sbagliato non deve sprecare tutto
l'impasto idea e prendiamo un po e cielo
forum e contro quella è una mattonella
questo è il meglio che siamo riusciti a
ottenere ragazzi bisogna metterla in
frigo di palermo tira fuori i venti sono
allergico alle attese inforniamo per 15
minuti quando deve essere 180 gradi 150
si erano 180 vabbè dai freghiamo c'è un
partito
attendiamo la prova l'altra elezioni e
stendiamo un velo pietoso prego come
tale di tutti i 100 giammarco non si
lancia il cibo è lei il diametro giusto
perché chiaramente tu non hai un anello
più piccolo ma chiaramente che sta
improvvisando in tutto perfetti
caspita comunque secondo mente andando
bene certe avendo mai fatto nulla
sostanzialmente in questa ricetta perché
questo dire sta facendo ma frullato il
robot da cucina ma quelli ha fatto il
robot ago cena e poi di quando michael
schumacher vinceva formula 1 valentino
rossi con la sua moto andava affatto
tutto una moto no no ha detto questo
cosa vuoi fare colpo danno piacere breve
un cattivo di ottenere sulle spine
vediamo cosa si inventa van gogh
no no no no cuore tipico degno della
biscuit pochino approssimativi di quelle
a the throne e hicks febbraio state
fermi così la palla è scaduta a ecco
perché 102 iv non me ne sa 180 gradi
è vero stando al tristi minuti di 200
aver bruciato
no io dico 8 vanno bene si per siamo
dorati
io non ho mai visto oro così nemmeno nel
collo di provata forse il collo di
globale della leggermente più errato
arrivato il momento dove vedremo se il
tuo come si chiama quel prodotto sta a
cantà spruzza funzione allo staccate
funziona sempre secondi a vabbè la mia
proposta è quella di iniziare a farci di
adesso e sono ancora caldi in modo che
capitola nutella se si intiepidisce
stende bene e poi a telecamere spente
citato è la telecamere spente è proprio
arrivato a un certo punto è arrivato
marchesi a darti una mano ha fatto con
tutto il rispetto del marchese non sto
dicendo che la grande marchesi anche
semplicemente illuminano di cucina
buttata è una bestemmia ma lui è uno
forte del settore ma se come era come
era ma era simpatico o antipatico come
chef c'era uno chef buono prima
conosciuto
ma perché ormai gli chef sembrano tutti
quanti incazzati perché erano scelto da
televisione e quindi non si può
conoscere miche come cracco e questi qua
di una maniera di è di marchesi che
diceva che stavamo cina non gli diceva
proprio questi diceva che gli mancava un
osso della mano perché era impreciso 9
quindi stai dicendo che crack o è scarso
in confronto a me che si sicuramente
basta questo di sindaco come lo è come
io ho visto comunque cosa peggiore di
davvero perché sei così auto critico o
biscotti a modella e ricordiamoci anche
che quest'anno all'amazzonia bruciato si
sono distrutti gli acciai siamo in un
momento di allarmi clima se ti sta
preoccupando di come sono venuti i miei
biscotti vogliamo diventare un post il
risulto canale o cattivi si sente un
pesce giusto dirlo non me ne frega
niente ostilissimo il rumore della
salvezza nel mondo della felicità no no
non ci credono però giocato al 35
milioni che devo fare che è colpa mia
non lo è anzi voglio dire che non me ne
frega niente due aspetti e se tu stai
guardando questo video aspetterei altri
minuti
sai perché perché ti piace questo video
e poi non ti stai facendo invece ti
piace vedi un pollice in su se lo metti
giù cioè notte e io sto in mezzo a una
fogna tina ricordo ne sono solo mano
anche ci sono crudi farina e burro
perfetti purtroppo grossi un guscio di
per farne siamo solo dei no no no ma non
può che si apre di un secondo
le cose cambino
si siano note ma lasciano sto cercando
di leggere il mercato cioè questo nuovo
a fatti danni così perché sei distinti
tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan
tan teheran per tanto tempo e saggia
materialità buttare nel cesso a
scaricare c'entra niente con lui scritto
se la famiglia usano delle quel tipo non
lo buono buono
no noi non ce ne sono cacchio
consistenza croccante identici anni
possono una cosa mettete cosa mangia un
altro per la casa famiglia mondo magni
un altro razzo e bella scelta e
lacerazioni e bonora e casa sulla 90
servizi ad alta volatilità peperino che
vediamo domani con un altro blog max
ciao ragazzi ci vediamo domani con un
altro ragazzo si passava la bocca